***
Die Lemuren aus "Madagascar".
Flipper.
Und Rudolph, the Red-Nosed Reindeer.
Sie alle sind Kindheitshelden.
Aber was wäre, wenn sie alle
ein dunkles Geheimnis hätten?
Etwas, das so schrecklich ist,
dass die Filmindustrie
es uns vorenthält?
Bei "Science vs. Fiction"
sprechen wir heute über Drogen.
Und zwar
in der Welt von süßen Tieren.
Also, haltet euch fest.
Es wird weird.
*Jazz-Musik*
Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Vor einiger Zeit habe ich mir
im Kino "Cocaine Bear" reingezogen.
Ich hatte nicht nur Mordsspaß.
Ein Bär ist auf Koks!
Ich bin danach hängengeblieben
auf dem Thema "Tiere und Drogen".
Ich schätze,
das verfolgt einen Mann für immer.
Das ist total crazy.
Ich habe von Kängurus gelesen,
die auf Schlafmohn-Plantagen
von den Mohnsamen naschen.
Anschließend
hüpfen sie zugedröhnt im Kreis.
♪ Gib mir das "Käng",
gib mir das "Gu".
♪ Gib mir das Buschkänguru.
Oder von russischen Braunbären,
die an Kerosin-Fässern schnüffeln.
Und von jeder Menge ...
♪ Saufi, saufi, saufi, saufi.
♪ Ich feiere richtig hart,
ich bin ein Sauf-Automat.
Am meisten schockiert
haben mich 3 Beispiele von Tieren,
bei denen ich
es nicht erwartet hätte.
Hollywood hat mir
was anderes vermittelt.
Also, lehnt euch zurück
und seid tapfer.
Denn jetzt zerstören wir vielleicht
einen Teil eurer Kindheit.
*lauter Schrei*
♪ I, I get so high.
King Julien, Mort, Maurice & Co.
sind neben den Pinguinen
die Stars der "Madagascar"-Reihe.
Die werden dort als putzige,
überdrehte Truppe präsentiert.
Von der könnte man vermuten,
dass sie wegen der House-Musik
ab und zu zu Ecstasy greifen.
♪ I like to move it, move it.
♪ You like to move it, move it.
She likes to move it, move it.
Die Wahrheit ist aber anders.
Die Lemuren im echten Leben
sind keine Party-Elements.
Schaut mal.
Die Bilder, die wir hier sehen,
sind von Mohrenmakis.
Das sind Lemuren.
Sie leben dort, wo der Film spielt:
im Nordwesten von Madagaskar.
Nur springen
die nicht fröhlich durch die Gegend,
sondern hängen
völlig zugedröhnt in den Bäumen.
Der Grund:
Auf dem Speiseplan der Lemuren
stehen auch diese Tausendfüßer.
Weil die das nicht geil finden,
gefressen zu werden,
sondern die ein giftiges Sekret ab,
um Fressfeinde abzuwehren.
Das Problem:
Während das bei Vögeln und Spinnen
ziemlich gut funktioniert,
juckt es Lemuren nicht.
Im Gegenteil:
Die kauen genüsslich darauf herum
und geraten in diesen Rauschzustand.
Aber warum machen die das?
Isn't that funny?
Ok, isn't that funny, haha!
Untersuchungen legen nahe,
dass der Rausch ein Nebeneffekt ist.
Der Zweck ist Insektenschutz.
Man sieht nämlich,
dass das Knabbern an den Tieren
für starken Speichelfluss sorgt.
Mit diesem Gemisch
aus Sabber und Giftsekret
reiben die Lemuren ihr Fell ein
und schützen sich damit vor Moskitos.
Und dadurch
am Ende sogar vor Malaria.
Das kann ich gut verstehen.
Denn wie nervig ist es bitte,
wenn du einen Trip genießen willst,
und ständig
terrorisieren dich Mücken?
(schreit) Ein Insekt,
ein Insekt in meiner Wohnung!
Es fliegt mir immer in die Fresse!
Ich hätte es fast verschluckt!
Andere Tipps unten in die Kommentare.
Ihr seht:
Um die Lemuren aus "Madagascar"
authentisch darzustellen,
bräuchte es nicht nur
eine unaufgeregtere Handlung.
*Er schreit irre.*
Und andere Musik.
*"I like to move it" ganz langsam.*
Sondern auch einen prüfenden Blick
vom Jugendschutz.
*lauter Schrei*
♪ I, I get so high.
Zugegeben, die Filme und Serien
über Flipper sind schon älter.
Das Original ist von 1963.
Aber der Plot ist super.
Ein Delfin und 2 Kids
erleben Abenteuer,
retten Menschen in Seenot
und bekämpfen Verbrechen.
Die perfekte Kinderserie.
Abgesehen davon,
dass die Produktion Tierquälerei war
und es eine Scheißidee ist,
Tiere in Gefangenschaft zu halten.
*Er kichert.*
Wenn du mir zustimmst, Flipper,
dann habe ich recht.
Auf dich sollte man hören.
Delfine gehören in die Freiheit,
ins offene Meer.
Nur dort können diese Geschöpfe
mit ihren Artgenossen
schwimmen, springen und ...
Drogen nehmen?
Diese Bilder
zeigen das absurde Schauspiel
einer exzessiven Drogenparty
in einer Gruppe Großer Tümmler.
Im Mittelpunkt ein Kugelfisch,
an dem sie knabbern.
Sie reichen ihn wie einen Joint
vom einen zum nächsten weiter.
Dieser Fisch ist dafür bekannt,
dass er ein Nervengift absondert,
wenn er sich bedroht fühlt.
Dieses Gift kann bei Menschen
zu Lähmungen und zum Tod führen.
Die Delfine aber
genießen das regelrecht.
Völlig berauscht
treiben sie an der Oberfläche
und starren ihre Reflexionen an.
Ein richtig heftiger Trip eben.
Anders als bei den Lemuren gibt es
keine sinnvolle Erklärung dafür.
Die Tiere
haben davon keinen anderen Nutzen
als den puren Rausch.
Als verantwortungsvoller Umgang
für Jugendliche
eignen sich Delfine nicht.
Ich glaube auch nicht,
dass Flipper in so einem Zustand
irgendjemanden in Seenot rettet.
Verstanden?
- (Kinder) Ja.
Aber diese Kugelfisch-Drogenparty
könnte im echten Leben
nützlicher sein als gedacht.
Das Kugelfisch-Gift
ist für die Forschung interessant.
Weil es
eine schmerzlindernde Wirkung hat,
könnte es für Narkosen
oder als Schmerzmittel nutzbar sein.
Und ein gesellschaftliches Problem
könnte man angehen, v.a. in den USA.
Dort gibt es ein Problem
mit Opioiden wie Fentanyl.
Das macht abhängig
und flutet den Schwarzmarkt,
mit krassen Folgen.
(Reporterin) Es ist für 80%
der Drogentoten verantwortlich.
Hier wird
auf offener Straße gekauft,
konsumiert und gestorben.
Forschende versuchen,
das Gift im Labor herzustellen.
Sie erhoffen sich dadurch
eine Alternative zu Opioiden.
Diese Alternative
hätte eine ähnliche Wirkung,
aber ohne abhängig zu machen.
Drogen erleben
eine Renaissance in der Forschung.
Psychedelika sind im Kommen,
Marihuana wird bereits eingesetzt.
Deshalb mal
die Gretchen-Frage an euch:
Bubatz legal:
Ja oder nein?
Schreibt mir.
Wir machen weiter
mit den nächsten Tier-Druffis.
*lauter Schrei*
♪ I, I get so high.
Der beste Buddy von Santa
ist wahrscheinlich der Letzte,
dem man ein Drogenproblem
unterstellen will.
Er trägt an Weihnachten
die Verantwortung.
Ok, man könnte wegen der roten Nase
auf Glühwein schließen.
Allein das wäre erschreckend.
Aber die Wahrheit ist viel schlimmer.
Dass das Rentier glaubt,
fliegen zu können,
hat in der echten Welt andere Gründe.
Rudolph und seine Artgenossen
stehen auf Magic Mushrooms.
Genauer gesagt: Fliegenpilze.
Das kann man überall beobachten,
wo Rentiere leben.
Von Skandinavien
über Sibirien bis Nordamerika.
Auf der Suche nach den Pilzen
legen sie weite Strecken zurück.
Auffällig ist auch,
dass sie dafür die Herde verlassen.
Wenn sie einen Pilz gefunden haben,
kann man beobachten,
wie sie komisch umhertorkeln,
seltsame Geräusche von sich geben.
Oder sie zucken mit dem Kopf.
Bevor ihr
nach einem tieferen Sinn dafür fragt:
Auch hier hat das nur einen Nutzen.
Der ist, dass Rentiere
anscheinend gerne high sind.
Damit sind sie keine Ausnahme.
Der Wissenschafts-Journalist
Andrew Haynes schrieb 2010 Folgendes:
Wenn ich mich in ein Rentier
versetzen müsste, würde ich sagen:
Die leben im Norden,
die Tage sind kurz, es ist kalt.
Vielleicht wollen die
der Monotonie entfliehen?
Was macht ihr
gegen Winter-Verstimmungen?
Tee und Kuscheldecke auf der Couch?
Esst ihr Pilze?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Ich bin Fan von Bier und Bratwurst.
Wenn ihr Rudolph auf Pilzen
schon weird findet,
dann wartet kurz, es ist nämlich so:
Der Verdauungstrakt von Rentieren
vollbringt wundersame Dinge.
Beim Stoffwechsel der Rentiere
wird die giftige Fliegenpilz-Säure
zu Muscimol abgebaut.
Das klingt,
als sei es danach weniger krass.
Aber die psychedelische Wirkung
wird sogar noch gesteigert.
Das Ganze
wird mit dem Urin ausgeschieden.
Jetzt wird's verrückt:
Das haben auch Naturvölker bemerkt.
Den Fliegenpilz zu konsumieren,
bringt einen Brechreiz mit sich.
Trinkt man aber Rudolphs Urin,
wird man high ohne sich zu übergeben.
Die Schamanen dieser Völker
haben Rentier-Pipi getrunken,
um berauscht zu sein.
Eklig, aber clever.
Erzählungen zufolge könnte sich so
ein Pinkel-Ritual ergeben haben.
Die Schamanen trinken Rentier-Urin,
ihre Anhänger den Schamanen-Urin,
und so kommen alle
in den Genuss von Pipi und Rausch.
Aber wissenschaftlich belegt
ist das nicht.
Forschende gehen eher davon aus,
dass berauschte Rentiere
leichte Jagdopfer waren.
Der Rausch der Menschen
hat sich beim Fleischverzehr ergeben.
Aber blicken wir auf Rudolph zurück,
können wir festhalten:
So zugedröhnt würde er
Weihnachten auf keinen Fall retten
oder Geschenke liefern.
Er würde es torpedieren.
Niemand kriegt was,
alle sind traurig.
Auf den Film können wir lange warten.
Das war unser Ausflug
in die Drogenwelt der Tiere.
Hat es euch gefallen,
freue ich mich über ein Like.
Wenn ihr keine Folge
mehr verpassen wollt,
müsst ihr abonnieren
und die Glocke drücken.
Ein Dank geht raus
an Dr. Mario Ludwig,
der uns unterstützt hat.
Und ein Hinweis:
Wenn ihr Drogen nehmt,
konsumiert verantwortungsbewusst.
Und nur über 18 Jahren.
Das gilt auch für Tausendfüßer,
Kugelfische und Fliegenpilze.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Apropos Tiere:
Wenn ihr
auf den Geschmack gekommen seid,
schaut hier oben rein
zu den "Phantastischen Tierwesen".
Wir haben geschaut,
welche es in echt gibt.
U.a. den Niffler.
Hier unten kommt ihr zum Video
von "Die da oben" über Cannabis.
Copyright MDR 2023